I think that that basketball was some of  the best basketball I will ever see for  the rest of my life do you feel that way  sure I think that was the highest level  of basketball being played  um  because it was only basketball and guys  were so locked in this you know you go  to the gym you have shoot around you eat  you  play  win or lose you you're in your room and  you go back to the gym if you want some  if you want to do something you want a  hobby  you just go to the gym you have a court  time from six to nine like that was all  we did you know so I'm not really  playing cards with your teammates you  know so  um guys were just locked in I was like  well I was talking about basketball I  was talking about coverages or I was in  the gym shooting Fritos  um  so it was just that was the only thing  we're doing and that helped me for sure  because that's the kind of guy I am to  stay locked in night and night out